- What a historic day.
So historic that
this just can't wait.
Trump sat down with
North Korean dictator,
Kim Jong-un to take the
first step towards peace.
As Churchill famously said,
the first steps
towards peace is a
thirsty photo op.
Look at that backdrop, iconic.
A wall of American
and North Korean flags
side by side.
A beautiful blur of
red white and blue.
You could hardly tell 'em apart.
But in this picture,
equals, partners.
The beginning of a
beautiful friendship.
Look at them
legitimizing each other
on the world stage.
Like Oprah did with books.
Trump gets it.
Reality is blurry.
Kim isn't a monster,
he's a talent.
- [Reporter] Kim Jong-un has
killed family members,
has starved his own people,
why are you so
comfortable calling
him very talented?
- Well he is very talented,
and anybody that takes
over at 26 years of age
and is able to run
it and run it tough,
- See? One man's
crimes against humanity
is another man's fiery
management style.
That's how Trump wants
to run our country.
Tough, with a whole new set of
tough, talented friends.
Just think of the
potential photo ops.
Darth Vader, he took
over pretty young, too.
Sharks, sure Trump hates
them but that's just
because of their rows
of super sharp talent.
The asteroid from "Armageddon".
It threatened Earth,
took out Bruce Willis
and set off the
chain of events that
led to Ben Affleck's
majestic back tattoo.
That's frightening true talent.
So get on board, Liberals,
this is what peace looks like.
A captured frozen
moment with no regard
for historical context.